Ukraine has denied any involvement in a
car bombing near Moscow that killed the
daughter of a prominent Russian
nationalist Dario dugina died in the
blast both she and her father Alexander
dugin have published publicly supported
Russia's war on Ukraine Russia's foreign
Ministry speculated that Kiev might be
behind the bombing but an adviser to
Ukraine's president said his country was
not a terrorist State
investigators sift through the remains
of the SUV driven by Daria dugina they
say an explosive planted in the vehicle
killed the 29 year old TV commentator
the power of the explosion was evident
parts of the Toyota Land Cruiser were
strewn across a large area
her father Alexander Dugan May however
have been the target of the attack
Russian State media said Dugan was
intending to travel in the vehicle but
changed his mind at the last minute
both Dugan and his daughter were on
their way to Moscow after they attended
a cultural Festival
Alexander Dugan is one of the staunchest
allies of President Vladimir Putin and a
far-right philosopher and author he has
been pushing for a Revival of the
Russian Empire his daughter although
less known was also a prominent member
of the ultra nationalist movement
supporting Russia's invasion of Ukraine
she called for genocide of ukrainians
she called ukrainians a sub-human Rays
she called for Public public killings of
Ukrainian prisoners of War Etc so yeah
she's a Dugan's daughter but she is
first of all a very active member of
Russian far-right nationalist Neo-Nazi
influential scene
a spokesperson for Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski has denied Kiev was
involved but pro-russian separatists say
Ukraine was behind the blast and
Russia's foreign Ministry spokeswoman
Maria zaharova said if the
investigation's trail led to Ukraine it
would amount to State terrorism
skip more now from DW's Yuri rashetto he
joins us from Riga is there any new
information Yuri on who might be behind
the attack
well at the moment Terry it's difficult
to say who is really behind at the debt
of Daria dugina but there are many
rumors and speculations depending on
which political Camp they come from the
supporters of Russia's so-called special
military operation Ukraine blamed tea
for wild critics over the Kremlin
suspect Russia's own intelligence
service or the pro-russian separatists
from dongbas Margarita simonyan the head
of Russia's State Finance broadcaster RT
blamed Ukraine and called for attacks
against Kiev the arguably most
well-known Theologian and former priest
Andre karives supposed that Russia's
intelligence service murder tadaria
jogena fearing that she might have made
too much competition for the established
parties in his opinion the Kremlin has
more to fear from the so-called radical
Patriots than liberals and yeah Leonid
volkov the fellow of the imprisoned
Russian opposition of politician
Alexander navalny he presumed that this
car bomb would even legitimate a new
wave of Terror in Russia
okay uh the father of the victim
Alexander Dugan has been described as
Putin's brain how much influence does he
really have on the Russian president
well nobody knows how much influence
Alexander dugina really has on Vladimir
Putin and some political experts assume
that his influence might be exaggerated
uh anyway Mr Dugan developed an extreme
right-wing view on Russia's place in the
world he stands for an anti-western
philosophy and philosophy and he is seen
as a kind of yeah intellectual father of
Vladimir Putin's plans to restore the
Russian Empire his daughter Daria dogena
was not only a follower of his
philosophy but also a kind of his
secretary she did her father's business
and she was a political scientist Daria
dugina gave comments on the propaganda
media in Russia she defiantly supported
President Putin at moscow's foreign
policy and in June she visited donbass
particularly the azov style plant in
mariupo
what does the killing of Daria dugina
mean for the Kremlin particularly in the
context of Russia's war against Ukraine
Yuri
well I think incidents like this Terry
is as well as several explosions in
different places in Russia close to the
Ukrainian Border in recent days whoever
might be behind them all these incidents
undermine uh definitely the kremlin's
narrative about security and stability
that Vladimir Putin supposedly stands
for the Russian president built his
reputation on stability after the
turbulent 1990s when deadly attacks were
commonplace in Russia and it's clear
that the war in Ukraine has now reached
to the Russian Capital Moscow with this
explosion moscovites expect at least
more identity checks more police on the
streets it does seem remarkable how the
frequency of attacks in Russia on
Russian territory has increased in
recent days and this could in fact be a
signal to the Russian Elites to the
Kremlin
Yuri thank you so much for now our
correspondent Yuri ruschetto there
well this story of course is being
closely followed in Ukraine DW's John
Philip Schultz is there in the capital
Kiev John Philip what do ukrainians make
of Daria dugina's killing
one of President zelenski's top advisors
went on TV and said that Ukraine has
nothing to do with the bombing he said
Ukraine is not a criminal State and does
not use such methods instead he blamed
internal power struggles in Russia of
course the sadness to surrounding the
death of dugina is quite limited here in
Ukraine by many people she was
considered an Enemy of the State and she
was also the target of Western sanctions
of course because of her lies about the
war in Ukraine at the same time there
are fears that the bombing could be
followed by some sort of Revenge and as
we heard before they have already been
called by prominent figures in Moscow to
have some sort of retaliation attacks on
Kiev
now talk to us young Philip about the
latest developments in the war there in
Ukraine where do things stand now on the
battlefield
once again some of the most worrisome
developments have to do with the famous
nuclear power plant in subordicia in the
city of nicopol which is just across the
river from the plant there have been at
least five different attacks in the past
hours and as you know the Russians are
accused of using the nuclear power plant
as a military basis to launch attacks in
the region there have also been more
attacks in the South and in the east of
the country especially in the region
around Odessa and in the donbass region
as well and what worries a lot of
ukrainians at the moment is that there
are reports about intensified attacks in
the coming days because on Wednesday
it's Ukraine's Independence Day and
president zelensky has already warned
ukrainians that Moscow could plan
something especially cruel in the coming
days
young Philip thank you so much our
correspondent young Philip Schultz there
in Kiev